our hands are incredible we use them to  manipulate objects and to sense the  world around us  that means the ideal prosthetic hand  should be able to move and feel at the  same time this robotic hand was  constructed by researchers from Cornell  University to provide a sophisticated  sense of touch it's soft construction  makes it more sensitive to the texture  and hardness of objects a sensor  embedded in the fingers uses optics to  convey information about pressure  texture and position researchers tested  the robotic hand by asking it to pick  out the ripeness tomato it gently  presses on each one just like you would  in the supermarket then it finds the  softest one and picks it out it can also  run its fingers along an object to  determine its shape and texture this is  just the prototype but it's simple  materials and 3d printed design should  make it easy to manufacture this  handsome robot could make life easier  for a lot of people  [Music]